So one way of speeding up hit times
is to overlap one hit with another,
and we can achieve this, for example,
through pipelining the cache.
If the cache takes
multiple cycles to access,
we can have a situation where an access
come in cycle N, and it's a hit.
And now if another access comes in
cycle N+1, and it would be a hit, too,
in a non-pipeline cache, this second
access has to wait until the first
access is done using the cache, and
it takes multiple cycles to do that.
So in this situation, the hit time,
as seen by each access,
is the actual hit time of a cache
plus the wait time that the access
suffers because it cannot access the
cache until the previous one is done.
And in that situation,
pipelining the cache so that we can send
in accesses one after the other
will improve the overall hit time.
Now it may sound straightforward
how to pipeline the cache.
You just divide it in,
let's say, three stages.
But how do you split
what amounts to basically
a read from a large array because
that's really what the cache is?
Remember that the cache access consists
of using the index part of the address
to find the set.
Reading out the tags and valid bits that
correspond to the blocks in that set.
Comparing the tags, and
checking the valid bits for
each of these to see
whether it has a hit.
Combining these so that we know
whether we have an overall hit and
where in our set.
Once we know where,
we read out the data and
use the offset to choose the right
part of the large cache block.
At which point, we have the data
that the processor wants, and
our cache access is done.
So one example of a cache pipeline
would be to have this part,
reading out the tags and so
on from the cache array, be stage one.
Determining the hits and
beginning the data read would be
stage two, and finishing the actual
data read all the way to getting
the data would be stage three.
So as you can see, we can pipeline
the cache access, even if we
don't know how to actually break down
the reading from the cache array,
especially if the tags and the valid
bits are read before we determine
the hit, and we only read the data part
of the cache after we determine the hit.
In that case,
just those two can be separate stages.
Usually, the actual cache hit time for
level one caches will be one, two or
three cycles.
One-cycle caches don't need pipelining,
and two- and three-cycle
caches can be relatively easily
pipelined into two or three stages.
So usually,
level one caches will be pipelined.